if you look at the
opinion data that we have on
how many black people americans believe
are killed every year unarmed by armed
american police officers
the figures are out by several orders of
magnitude um i've got the percentages in
that
among among people who describe
themselves as very liberal
uh significant proportion of them think
that more than 10 000 black men
are killed every year by american police
when those men are unarmed it's
something the real number i don't know
somewhere around 10. yeah it's about a
dozen yeah which is actually less than
the number of policemen killed by armed
black men so there's another debate
there yeah but yes i mean so it's off by
several orders of magnitude people
describe themselves as liberal
uh think that it's somewhere between one
thousand and ten thousand so you're
dealing with a completely grotesque
distorted picture of the present that
people in america and then around the
world have been persuaded to fall for
and that has consequences
all right so let's uh let's start at the
beginning
chapter one is about race and we've
already touched on some of the race
stuff
i guess when i think about it
and when i was reading it it's um we
almost solved the race thing in america
we were pretty damn close you alluded to
that in the book we really were pretty
damn close and now it does seem worse
maybe not in my day-to-day life but at
the media level the societal level does
seem worse what a what a sad statement
it's um it's partly i believe a
misapprehension caused by a
misrepresentation of the society
so
uh obviously i may have to get straight
into it in the race chapter the death of
george floyd the summer of george floyd
riots
um
[Music]
the if you look at the i mean we were
all it's always worth reminding
ourselves
in most countries at that point we were
made to seclude ourselves
in the months before that happened
people were literally isolated and told
by government to isolate and one of the
things that did to us i believe is that
it took away our societal antenna
you know um if we meet people if we meet
strangers friends and everything we sit
around a dinner table or stand a bar um
you try things out and you row about
things and you discuss things and you
josh about things and and much more if
if you remove all of that
um
and then something terrible happens
and a group of very dedicated people say
that shows x is the case
then
you know people start to think maybe
that is maybe that is the case now i was
in britain when
george floyd
was killed but you know um
i had a moment i've known this i've
known america all my life
and i i did a slight double take moment
like you know
i don't think you can just kill
black people in america i'm fairly sure
you can't i know you can't
uh but here were these protests saying
we've got to stop the fact that black
people walking the streets of america
can at any point be killed by a cop
and that's that's not true
um but there was a moment of doubt uh
which is one of the reasons why police
forces in among other things countries
like my own country of birth and britain
really didn't know what to do at the
beginning of the protests and some
policemen were persuaded to take the
knee to protesters because they panicked
i thought maybe this representation that
we've been shown is true
if you look at the
opinion data that we have on
how many black people americans believe
are killed every year unarmed by armed
american police officers
the figures are out by several orders of
magnitude
um i've got the percentages in that
among among people who describe
themselves as very liberal
a significant proportion of them think
that more than 10 000 black men
are killed every year by american police
when those men are unarmed it's
something the real number i don't know
somewhere around 10. yeah it's about a
dozen yeah which is actually less than
the number of policemen killed by armed
black men so there's another debate
there yeah but yes i mean it's so it's
off by several orders of magnitude
people describe themselves as liberal
uh think that it's somewhere between one
thousand and ten thousand so you're
dealing with a completely grotesque
distorted picture of the present
that people in america and then around
the world have been persuaded to fall
for
and that has consequences
um
because if you're told that this is the
case and that you live in a society this
race then you bring up white people to
believe that they are somehow
contaminated from birth
you bring up young black kids to believe
that they are able to be hunted down and
killed in america by the state
you massively exacerbate all racial
differences
but what this has fallen into has been
this not just what i described as war on
white people but this
this
set of massive overreach claims about
what is underneath this you know well
we've always been like this you know and
so we have the starting of the rewriting
of our history in the name of racial
justice and social justice in america
you have a 1619 project no small thing
it's the new york times that rolls that
out
led by non-historian non-specialists who
make totally
verifiably false claims about the
foundations of this country
but you see the same thing in the uk in
canada
a lot of people will have missed it but
around the same time in the last couple
years there's been this stampede in
canada when there was some graves that
were found
near a church school
and then it was claimed that this these
were mass graves and chilled indigenous
children killed by the catholic church
in massive numbers
and churches were burnt down across
canada including first nations churches
[Music]
not one body has been found
not one excavation has occurred
they didn't even use ultrasound
so we we have been
embedding
totally false
claims about our collective pasts
in the names of trying to refine the
present
what do you make of the way it spreads
that that falsehood and how it's spread
so you go into the numbers about what's
going on with policing in america but
there were blm riots in london as you
mentioned that the the way it now
spreads through the internet to then
land on the shores overseas for a
problem that nobody if you would have
asked the average person i suspect if
you asked the average black person in
london four years ago do you have a real
problem with policing here i'm going to
guess that the average person would have
said no maybe somebody had some marginal
thing but what do what do you make of
that that that transfer oh yeah i mean
there was a head of um
blm movement in oxford
uh um called sasha johnson i'll be
careful what i say about her because i
believe she's still in hospital
sasha johnson wrote a tweet as head of
red led some very unpleasant protests uh
said horrible things about white people
said on social media she wanted to make
white people her slaves that that was
the plan she said she didn't want
equality she wanted revenge
um
by the way she's nice when they're
honest about it she was completely
honest about it i say i'm being careful
about because she's a mother and she uh
was at a house party in london uh last
year and she was shot in the head
and immediately some politicians
including the black former shadowhold
secretary said
it's appalling this poor young woman has
been gunned down for her beliefs she was
gunned down by a gang of black young men
who
were shooting at a house party she was
at
so again we have these kind of just
totally false narratives you import the
blm thing to oxford in england
and then you have this horrible radical
and then something terrible happens then
all of it all of it is spun through the
thing of
white racism
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell